Aujourd’hui on est le 14 avril 2017
et c'est mon anniversaire.
Et là je vais peut-être vous choquer,
mais j'ai trente ans.
Et ouais !
Mais franchement, je le vis plutôt bien           (BOUUUUMM) ,  FAUX !!
Alors je sais, physiquement on dirait pas du tout que j'ai trente ans.
Mais je vous rassure dans la vie on me considère quand même comme un adulte.
"le petit Norman est demandé à l'accueil"
Deux secondes, j'arrive.
" si vous trouvez cet enfant, merci"
Mais quand même, je le sens que j'ai trente ans.
Mon corps change,
j'ai un peu de bide,
des poils qui sortent d'endroits improbables,
comme le nez,
ou les oreilles.
Je commence à avoir ce qu'on l'on appelle des "golfs"
enfin... des minis golfs. BATOUTII LE BEST
Et grande nouvelle, j'ai de la barbe !
Enfin vite fait...
Disons qu'à partir du moment où tu dois faire aux gens:
Mais si si j't'jure j'ai de la barbe !
Touche, regarde, de plus près !
C'est que t'as pas de barbe.
J'ai trente ans et, j'le ressens dans mon comportement
Je commence à acheter des produits bio
des fois je m'en fout d’être stylé, je préfère être à l'aise.
J'aime de plus en plus acheter des objets...inutiles.
Odeur pluie sous la cabane !
Parfois je râle en regardant un politique à la télé.
Alors Fillon lui... Pff !
Parfois j'utilise un parapluie.
Parfois je fais des brunchs.
Alors ça c'est du quinoa sans gluten,
ça c'est du tofu détox
et ça bah c'est de la pelouse.
Du stade de France.
Qui a été foulée par Antoine Griezman
Et puis parfois je dis des phrases de trentenaires.
"c'était quand même pas mal hein, MC Solar"
et si je m'achetai un vélo pliable ?
À terme, tout le monde sait qu'il vaut mieux acheter que louer.
Je pense que je vais investir dans la pierre.
Alors, j'ai un projet, tu vas peut-être me prendre pour un taré,
mais je vais peut-être construire mon potager et faire pousser mes propres salades
Tu sais à 40 ou 50 ans,
les gens osent pas trop te parler de ton âge.
Pour pas te vexer
Mais à 30 ans, tout le monde se fout de ta gueule ouvertement hein, c'est pas un problème !
"Regardez comment il est vieux, il a 30ans !"
"Sale papy va! Tu vas bientôt mourir !"
Maintenant que j'ai 30ans,
je commence à avoir les fameux "coups de vieux".
Par exemple quand je vais sur un site où tu dois indiquer ton année de naissance.
En fait j'ai plus envie de m'inscrire.
Ou alors quand je croise des jeunes qui m'appellent Monsieur.
Ça fait mal !
Mais le pire c'est quand j'entends des ados parler,
et qu'il y a une expression que je ne comprends pas.
Là je me dis,
"Ça y est, je suis une merde"
En même temps je suis désolé mais,
quand t'es un adulte dans la vie active,
tu peux pas utiliser des expressions d'ado.
Alors à c'kip vous cherchez un bail bresson à temps partiel
Haha... quel FDP !
Alors ça sert à rien de forcer hein, c'est la haass
Hum, j'suis déso mais là d'office j'ai rien"
-Vous êtes sûr ?
-Eh mais t'es dans l'excès là j'te jure...
...Tu me fatigue ! J'en peux plus de toi !
Bon j'vous laisse quand même ma carte, dessus y'a mon snap. Envoyez pas des nudes hein !
J'ai quand même une femme hein !
Maintenant que j'ai 30ans. C'est-à-dire, depuis 4 heures,
Je réalise qu'il y a plein de truc que je pourrais plus jamais faire.
Alors astronaute, non,
Entrer dans la NBA, non,
Danseur étoile, ah, quoique, peut-être !
Disons que maintenant quand je parle à quelqu'un,
Je peux parfois avoir une certaine forme euh...
D'autorité...
Bon écoute, je vais te parler franchement,
maintenant tu arrête de me manquer de respect !
Et tu mange tes croquettes!
Merde !
Et quand je compare mes 20ans à mes 30ans,
je trouve que les choses ont beaucoup changé.
Avoir 20ans et avoir 30 ans, c'est pas du tout pareil !
Frère, j'ai acheté une nouvelle planche de skate,
je vais mettre les roues dessus, là pour faire de la rampe,
c'est parfait ça !
- Tu vas faire ça sans protections ?
- Bah évidemment !
- Mon gars, je me suis acheté une nouvelle planche de skate,
elle fait une parfaite étagère pour poser mes livres !
- Ah ouais ?! Mais tu l'as installée tout seul ?
- Ouais, par contre j'ai mis les genouillères, les coudières, le casque !
- Putain les mecs, camping sauvage pour 3 semaines
à 3 dans la même tente, énorme !
- Yes ! Moi j'ai une pierre pointue dans le dos mais je m'en tape,
franchement je kiffe là !
-Woh y a des mecs bourrés qui tombent sur notre tente !
- Hé viens prendre un bière mec!
- Cet hôtel est pas fifou quand même !
- Ouais les oreillers ils sont hyper durs.
- Ouais
- Ouais ouais
- ouais
Mon gars, cette console c'est ma nouvelle passion !
J'arrête pas d'y jouer ! Téma les graphismes !
Oh !!
Mon gars, je me suis acheté un petit mixeur fruits et légumes,
je me fais des jus, mais des jus !
Carotte pamplemousse ! Et là je viens de tenter pomme cactus.
Bah tiens goutte en premier !
OK mec ! Ton manteau je le met là avec les autres !
Comment il va ?!
Tiens pour ton manteau je te donne un petit cintre.
Est-ce que je peux aussi te donner un petit cintre pour le pantalon ?
Parce que ça va salir les fauteuils.
Et est-ce que ton slip est propre?
Parce que j'ai des petits cintres à slip aussi.
Ça, ça s'appelle un cercueil !
C'est un mélange de téquila, de sky, et d'essence pur !
- Bois ça direct !
- Bois ! Bois ! Bois !
Il est surprenant ce petit bordeaux !
- Très agréable !
- Pas plus de 2 verres, après je conduis.
- Mange le chèvre ! Mange le chèvre ! Mange le chèvre !
- Attention ! Mâche bien sinon tu vas mal digérer.
- Ha ha ha ! Surtout qu'avec mes brûlures d'estomac...
Allez je me lance !
- Hé frère hier j'étais tellement torché, je me souviens de rien du tout !
- C'est clair ! On remet ça ce soir ou quoi ?!
- T'es sérieux là ? On remet ça maintenant !
- Ouais !
- Frère je suis dans le mal ! À la soirée je me suis tellement bourré la gueule !
- La soirée c'était y a 2 mois !
- Ouais mais quand même !
Enfin... j'avais quand même bu 2 flûtes !
Finalement quand on a 30 ans,
j'ai un peu l'impression qu'on se situe juste là.
Pile poil au milieu.
Entre jeune, et vieux.
Des sortes de jieux.
Je dis pas ça pour me rassurer,
mais je trouve que de nos jours à 30 ans,
on est quand même un poil niveau jeune, encore.
Alors qu'à l'époque, les jeunes étaient très rapidement vieux.
Vraiment.
Et puis quand j'y réfléchis,
y a quand même plein de points positifs à avoir 30 ans.
Déjà je fais parti d'une génération qui a connu des trucs de ouf.
La coupe du monde 1998,
l'an 2000,
Titanic au cinéma,
la naissance d'internet,
et puis quand même, les pogs.
À 30 ans on a accumulé plein de potes depuis l'école,
et puis on sait enfin faire la différence entre les connaissances,
et les vrais amis.
À 30 ans si t'as de la chance dans la vie tu fais ce que t'aimes.
T'as des projets de plus en plus gros.
T'es plus fort,
t'as un peu plus confiance en toi,
et t'es plus convaincant devant les gens.
T'as un peu de vécu alors t'as des choses à raconter,
et en même temps t'as l'envie et l'énergie de découvrir et d'apprendre encore.
Et au final je pense que le plus important quand t'as 30 ans,
c'est de pas faire semblant d'avoir moins.
Simplement d'assumer son âge et le vivre pleinement.
Parce que, cet âge, il est aussi cool que les autres.
À sa manière.
Et mine de rien, l'expérience qui t'a forgée pendant 30 années,
a fait du petit garçon qui était en toi,
un homme.
Yes !
Grâce à la nouvelle mise à jour YouTube,
quand vous cliquez ici, là, sur ce bouton,
depuis un téléphone, ou un ordi,
bah ça fait un truc nouveau !
Allez-y essayez, cliquez.
Avec votre doigt ou votre souris.
Voilà.
Pas mal non ?!
Plutôt cool, hyper simple pour s'abonner,
beaucoup plus instinctif, donc merci monsieur YouTube,
et puis merci à vous, je vous aime énormément !
Lâchez un petit pouce en l'air svp.
Au revoir.